-This is your ninth time
on the show.
-It is?
-Yeah.
You're a record-setter
over here.
-That's good. What record?
-Most times on the show.
-Oh! Boy.
[ Laughter ]
For me?
-I thought that was patently
obvious from the setup.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very excited -- this is
garden season for you.
-It is.
Oh, my garden is so great.
Today I was photographing
cabbages and string beans.
-And what do you do
with those photos?
[ Laughter ]
-I put them on Instagram.
-You put them on Instagram.
Do you get a lot of likes?
Is there a lot of traffic
on your Instagram?
Does, like, cabbage do better
than, like, green beans,
or is it about the same?
-Cabbages do really well.
-Cabbages do really well?
What do you attribute that to,
the popularity of...
-Well, they're pretty.
-Yeah.
-You know, they're prettier than
string beans.
-Would you say
there's a bigger gap
between how pretty cabbage looks
and how bad it tastes?
[ Laughter ]
-I think it tastes great.
-You like cabbage.
But is there any food
you don't like, though?
-Um, brains.
-Okay.
-Livers.
Oh, actual brains,
like, yeah, you know...
I thought you were,
like, doing comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- That's my garden.
See, look how pretty
the tomatoes look.
-So those are --
those tomatoes --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, see how nice?
-Guys, if you like
her vegetables,
please, on Instagram only.
[ Laughter ]
Please only --
So, what are --
Have you tented
your tomato plants?
-Well, they're all
trellised on bamboo.
And we've tried a new method
this year.
And it's working very well.
So, the bamboo criss-crosses,
and the tomatoes
go up and then out.
-That's what we do.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I am a little jealous.
I said this
last time you were here
that you partnered up
with Snoop Dogg
to do your
"Potluck Dinner" show.
-Can I ask Nate
to come on our show?
-Nate? You want Nate
to come on your show?
-Yeah, yeah.
-All right.
Nate, you just got invited...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...to "Potluck Dinner."
Does Snoop bring stuff
to the party
that, like, maybe,
you don't bring?
-All guests stop
in Snoop's...
-Dressing room.
-...trailer.
-Trailer. Okay, gotcha.
At the end of the day,
does Snoop's trailer
smell different
than your trailer?
[ Laughter ]
-Not only the inside
but the outside.
-Yeah. So it's --
-I just have to stand outside.
-Oh, gotcha.
You have a couple of new dogs.
One "G."
-I do. Look.
-Yeah, and these
are puppies, right?
-Look, those are puppies.
[ Audience awws ]
Those are the new chow puppies.
We had a litter of four.
I kept Emperor Han.
That's Emperor Han over here.
-Uh-huh.
-And he's really great.
And his half-sister
is with me, too.
And that's Empress Qin.
-Empress Qin and Emperor Han?
-Yes.
-Um, those are some pretty
pretentious names, Martha.
[ Laughter ]
-They're Chinese.
They are.
They're the royal dogs.
-They're the royal dogs.
-Yeah.
-And do you have baby peacocks?
Is that true?
-I have baby peacocks.
I have one in my kitchen
right now.
It hatched two days ago.
-Oh, and then, how long
do they stay in the kitchen?
-Well, until
they drive me crazy.
-How long does it take
for a peacock to get old enough
to not be --
-Like about three weeks.
They chirp and chirp
all night and all day.
-Do you tend to them?
Is that why
they're in the kitchen?
-Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
But they have to stay warm.
You know, they're tiny
when they're born,
and then they grow
to about this big
and then you can put them out
with the other peacocks.
-Gotcha.
When does the feather part of it
start happening?
-That happens in two years.
It's a long, tedious process.
-Well that's...
[ Laughter ]
I just don't have
the time for peacocks.
I don't know how...
[ Laughter ]
-Until they get mature,
they're just boring.
-They're just boring, yeah.
-But they're very friendly.
-Kids are very similar.
I would say about two is
when they come into their own.
You have a new line.
I can't believe
this is the first --
Is this a new line of apparel?
-No, no, but it's
a new line for now.
-Okay.
-And it's so beautiful.
I brought you something.
-I think it's right there.
-Oh, yeah.
You even know where it is, see?
Look, I know you have
a tiny dog.
-Yeah.
-So this is the latest, coolest
little jacket.
[ Audience awws ]
it's a gold motorcycle jacket.
-A gold motorcycle jacket.
-So when you...
-I think if my...
-And the little collar.
Look at the collar.
-Oh, my God, that's amazing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think if I -- if my dog
Frisbee wore this,
people who would look at Frisbee
would be like,
"That's a cool dog,"
and then they would look at me
walking her
and be like,
"And you're an ass[Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no.
People will really want that
jacket when they see it...
-Yeah.
-...on your dog.
-On my dog? That's great.
Well, I mean, we're going to --
we'll have a photo.
Will you Instagram a photo of
Frisbee if we send you one?
-Please do.
-Okay, good. I will.
I'm very excited.
So Jonathan Rhys Meyers is
our next guest,
and you're going to stay.
You're a huge
Jonathan Rhys Meyers fan.
-I am, I am.
I'm still recovering
from "The Tudors."
-Yeah.
-You know, he kills five wives.
I think it's five.
And he's --
-And you were drawn to that?
[ Laughter ]
-Henry VIII was sexy.
-Yeah, Henry VIII was sexy.
-Especially as played
by Jonathan Rhys Meyers.
-Well, now, this is
bringing me back,
because I have a chip
on my shoulder
about Jonathan Rhys Meyers.
-Why?
-Well, it's your fault.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
I know. I know what it is.
-Years ago, I'd never been
on your show before.
It was the first time I was
on your show as a guest.
I got asked, like, day of,
"Will you do Martha Stewart?"
And then I showed up,
and when I came out,
you just told the whole audience
the reason I was there was
Jonathan Rhys Meyers cancelled.
-He had cancelled.
[ Laughter ]
-And Meyers, Meyers -- he was
the next Meyers on the list.
[ Laughter ]
We were just going down
alphabetically.
-It's very big of me --
It's very big of me
to let you stay out,
but you're gonna stay out.
-But you were
such a great guest,
and you were on my show
several times.
-Yeah, I was on your show
-And Jonathan was on also
several times.
-Don't do this again.
Don't make this about Jonathan.
You're going to stick around.
We're going to get to the bottom
of who you love the most.
Martha Stewart, everybody.